[Music]
this morning on the dish a chef who
starred in the food business was truly
an accident born and raised in New
Jersey Evan rich had just started to
drive when he wrecked his parents car
and had to get a job as a dishwasher to
pay down the damages but that led to
other restaurant jobs a degree from the
prestigious Culinary Institute of
America and a career as an executive
chef then came the time to create his
own place with wife Sarah he opened San
Francisco's rich table and followed it
up with arti rotisserie with a second
location opening this spring a few
months ago they published their rich
table cookbook and chef Evan rich good
morning welcome to that dish thank you
for having which it got here on the
table for us alright so we got some
sweet potato pancakes with a apricot
salsa verde broccolini that's grilled
New York Strip with a green bean
chimichurri and fried shallots
we got spaghetti with peas goat cheese
and a little bit of duck fat then on the
end there are some dried porcini dusted
donuts with a raclette cheese dipping
sauce that those make the world go round
and our cocktail oh and then the
cocktail is called the Lands End and
it's a little to origin with some
locally sourced spruce so Anthony said
this literally your career started
because of that accident which got you
into the kitchen yeah dishes but how do
you go from washing dishes to then
getting to cooking so in a kitchen you
always take on way more responsibility
than you should and so washing dishes
then you had a little extra time prep
some cookies make some soup and I just
you know kind of kept taking on
responsibilities I guess I was a real
good dish but you were still planning to
be basically a ski bum in Colorado
exactly until you and your mom walked by
the Helena Ranch to do well yeah so
actually my mother took me to the
college fair at my high school yeah and
she said four years of college you have
to go we're paying
yeah I'm going to Colorado I'm skiing oh
so she walked me past the Culinary
Institute and she was like cooking you
like cooking and I remember the moment
in my head it was like huh that'll be
good that's easy yeah I've got a job
cooking on the resort and then I
couldn't you know get a free ticket and
then you know the rest is history you go
to culinary school you learn about the
history the focus and that and it kind
of spirals out of control from there
there's one chef that left a big
impression on you mm-hmm why I think
chef David Boulais probably left one of
the biggest impressions number one
that's where I met my wife she was my
boss there that yeah boss yeah yeah it
was your Michelle Obama yeah exactly
she kind of you know gave me the
approval in the restaurant that everyone
kind of you know started looking at me
like a serious cook there was another
involving a pea soup soup oh okay so
every day she worked my station in the
morning I worked her station at night
and she would help me prep and she made
the sauces and I would always joke
around with this pea sauce we would make
and it was like super difficult to make
you had to shuck like cases of peas and
I would always be like I dropped the pea
soup you got to make new and then one
day I was like oh I'm just kidding
and I like twitch or something and
dropped it and she had to make it all
over again and she had to stay super
late I make she liked you all along yeah
exactly well and I didn't get it I you
know I was just like this she makes me
look so good she always doesn't like
station prep to clean you know and she's
pulling on the pigtail so was it your
dream the two of you to open your own
place together yeah it was our focus you
know we we left New York so she dragged
me out of New York my family tri-state
area brewing through and then one day
she was like you know we're leaving New
York where do you want to go I'm not me
I was like I don't know Jersey
[Laughter]
you know like go wet then gee you know
her family was out west so we went out
west and kind of went up and down the
coast and found in San Francisco to just
be beautiful and the food team was
amazing the vegetables the you know
everything was great and we naively were
like we're gonna go out there and open
up in a year and went and got a job and
you know got our butts kicked got some
serious jobs and we're like wow I guess
you know they cook really well other
places
yes they do yeah what is the division of
labor that's what you know it's her it's
her world I live well have you signed
the dish yeah let me ask you if you
could have this meal with anyone pastor
president who would it be
you know I think I think the the safe
answer is my grandmother because like
she never was around to see kind of what
I became and I feel like this is all
like inspired by her Sunday dinners Oh
to have with the family and we used to
all hang out and cook and that that's
how my family hung out yeah I would say
Steve Jobs you know I'm from I'm from
San Francisco but he just had this eye
for detail and like this ability to coax
greatness out of people you know and
it's just like talking to him and you
know getting some money eating greatness
yeah exactly
I've been rich thank you so much of
course we're on Evan in the dish you can
head to our website CBS this morning
calm